nous on va faire le point tout de suite
avec le docteur carves dr weiss bonsoir
alors les variants vous en êtes où on
voit les chiffres
oui c'est une augmentation mais les
hospitalisations pour l'instant ça tient
là ça va être encore est-ce que vous
c'est inévitable dans votre esprit
il va avoir une remontée parce que le
variant plus contagieux alors la
bataille des variants est perdue pour le
québec parce que ça fait déjà des mois
que les variants sont là on a à peu près
25 à 30% nos souches qui sont des
variants aujourd'hui dans mon hôpital
44% des souches étaient des variants
donc pratico pratique ce qui va arriver
le variant est à une souche si vous
voulez plus habilités à se transmettre
plus compétitive à prendre le dessus sur
l'ancienne souche et donc elle va se
retrouver le deuxième point la majorité
des variants quasiment 30 à 35% sont
isolées chez des gens de moins de 19 ans
donc chez des adolescents et des enfants
et une autre grosse partie chez les
parents de ces gens là donc oui on
risque de voir une augmentation des cas
pas forcément des hospitalisations
pourquoi parce que si on regarde les
plus de 70 ans il représente un très
faible taux est très faible pourcentage
des variants pourquoi parce qu'on les a
vacciné et ça montre que la vaccination
c'est la grande nouvelle de la journée
c'est à mon sens c'est pas tellement les
variants c'est pas tellement le fait de
parler d'une troisième vague
hypothétique ou pas qui a relativement
peu d'importance c'est le fait qu'on a
vacciné 55000 personnes au québec et
qu'on a eu notre meilleur jour de
vaccination à date
parce que quand on voit quand on va
signer les gens par exemple les plus de
70 ans
les variants chez ces gens là il y en a
pas beaucoup et comme ce sont les gens
de plus de 60 ans qui malheureusement
décès vont à l'hôpital vont soins
intensifs si on arrive à protéger ce
groupe là est dans une étape très rapide
je l'espère protéger tous les patients
qui ont des facteurs de risque autres au
moins on va protéger le système
hospitalier
bon ben je trouve que vos propos dr
weill sont nature assez rassurant est ce
que est ce que dans votre esprit vous
dites ça pas d'importance à troisième
vague mais ce que dans votre esprit
quand même il y aura
forcément une augmentation et à ce que
dans votre esprit surtout le
gouvernement doit reculer sur les
mesures d'assouplissement
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une augmentation
fort probablement c'était prévu mais est
ce que ça va être une troisième bac on
peut discuter de la sémantique pendant
longtemps sa recrue d'importance
oui il va y avoir une augmentation est
ce que le gouvernement doit changer des
affaires c'est un équilibre
il ya des choses qui sont qu'on comprend
par exemple faire du sport ouvrir les
jim oui aller par exemple ouvrir des
salles de spectacles pour que les gens
puissent se divertir par des conditions
sécuritaires oui ce qu'on comprend
beaucoup moins et c'est des gros point
d'interrogation c'est d'ouvrir les lieux
qu avec 250 personnes ce qui a à peu
près beaucoup de bon sens et évidemment
aussi le fait par exemple que il ya
certaines choses qu'on veut entre
guillemets ramener les enfants du
secondaire à l'école à temps plein alors
qu'on approche de la fin de l'année
scolaire et que tout semble être en
place pour que l'enseignement se fasse
de façon adéquate et cetera sachant que
les variants sont beaucoup dans le
groupe d'âge des enfants des enfants ou
des adolescents qui vont secondaire
docteur vincent termina je parle au
docteur marquis tout à l'heure qui me
disaient qu'ils avaient vus aux soins
intensifs chez lui à maisonneuve
heureusement un homme de 50 ans par
exemple à ces malades est ce que vous
vous constatez déjà maintenant
aujourd'hui des gens plus jeunes dans
votre hôpital qu'on doit se finaliser
alors tout à fait des ça ça fait déjà
depuis le quasiment de trois mois
il comparaît à la première vague des
patients qu'on a aujourd'hui sont
beaucoup plus jeunes si on se projette à
ce qui a été fait dans d'autres pays dès
que vous vacciner massivement une
catégorie gage vous surtout les plus
âgés
vous voyez que la proportion de ces gens
là qui arrive aux soins intensifs
diminue de façon très intense donc les
patients qu'on voit aujourd'hui sont un
peu plus jeune que ce qu'on voyait lors
de la première vague et d'où
l'importance d'aller vacciner maintenant
très rapidement les patients cancéreux
les gens qui ont des problèmes
cardiaques pulmonaires lesquels effet
cetera jeunes pas seulement ceux qui ont
60 ans et plus
les autres aussi dr weiss je vous quitte
mais vraiment retient
mon vaccin vous n'êtes plus on y recrute
plus on ira vite dans la vaccination
plus on va voir la pub on a peut-être
n'était pas si mal de vent c'est notre
objectif il faut que le 24 juin
l'immense majorité du québec soient
vaccinés pour qu'on puisse sortir de ça
et il faut vraiment accélérer la
campagne de vaccination merci beaucoup
d'acteurs vaisala prochaine merci au
revoir